auch so sieht judentum heute in
deutschland aus helene janine braun ist
quer weilt rabbinerin und auf instagram
aktiv dort kostet sie über religion
sexualität und berliner lifestyle und
vertritt damit eine generation die all
das verbindet viele menschen ja in der
schule über das judentum lernen ist ja
wirklich furchtbar also sie lernen ja
gar nichts oder sie lernen was über den
nationalsozialismus aber nicht über
lebendiges judentum bis heute gelebt
wird und deswegen ist das auch so muss
sondern mein ziel geworden einfach so
viel durchs leben zu zeigen
helene ist religiös aufgewachsen
für sie sind einfach zu wenig frauen in
hohen ämtern
das will sie ändern nach ihrem studium
wird die 23 jährige wahrscheinlich die
jüngste rabbinerin deutschland seien
auch um eine ansprechperson zu sein die
sie selbst nie hatte für mich ist ganz
klar dass niemand sich zwischen seiner
jüdischen und seiner queren identität
unterscheiden
entscheiden soll denn du kannst es dir
eben nicht aussuchen du wirst ja mit
seiner sexualität geboren oder du
entwickelst du dich mit deiner
sexualität und wenn du jüdisch bist dann
soll es auch beides leben kann dass man
in der jüdischen gemeinschaft so weit
gekommen ist ist auch frauen zu
verdanken wie dieser berg
sie musste noch dafür kämpfen überhaupt
als rabbinerin anerkannt zu werden
es gab leute die den raum verlassen
haben wenn ich ihn betreten habe ich hab
dann irgendwann dafür gesorgt dass ich
immer früh genug da war weil dann saß
ich schon und dann mussten die anderen
überlegen ob sie sich dazusetzen oder
nicht dieser berg ist zum judentum
konvertiert nun leitet sie die neue
synagoge in berlin mitte in berlin gab
es auch die erste rabbinerin überhaupt
regina jonas sie war allerdings nur
religionslehrerin die zusätzlich
rabbinische seelsorgerische betreuung
übernehmen durfte
da ist sie und man sieht ja auch quasi
das zentrale was sie auch belohnt
gott hat nicht nach dem geschlecht
gefragt also sie wollte einfach rabbiner
in sein
sie bringt die einzige das hat aber mit
der shoah zu tun ist gehabt wohl andere
junge frauen die in die gleiche richtung
gedacht und geträumt haben und für mich
ist es einfach wunderbar nicht die erste
zu sein was immer mitschwingt als juden
in deutschland die geschichte der shoah
auch regina jonas wurde von den nazis
ermordet sie musste ihren glauben mit
dem leben bezahlen
und heute der antisemitismus ist lauter
geworden ist vor allem auch
unverschämter geworden und versteckt
sich häufig hinter so einem man muss
doch noch mal sagen dürfen
judentum heute ist so vielfältig wie
seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr in
deutschland
leute wie helene wollen sich das nie
wieder nehmen lassen